Oxford dictionary's just announced the
word of the year for 2015 which is the
crying laughing emoji reporting that it
makes up to 17% of all emoji use in the
United States I know you're all thinking
how is it not the eggplant okay we're
gonna go talk to some people about their
emoji use and see what this thing what
is the emoji you use most often
it's either the cry laugh and emoji or
it's like a little sassy lady yeah what
is this guy definitely the tongue
sticking out emoji like that the word of
the year for 2015 is the crying laughing
emoji do you agree well that's stupid
it's not a word an emoji how is an emoji
a word are they words no is that where
we are with life maybe a picture is
worth a thousand of them so that's so
cool that's [ __ ] dope please believe
that I use that all the time just for
anything both positive and negative I
think that's the perfect emoji to be
like my life is so hard and I'm really
stressed but at the same time I'm
laughing about it when you can
communicate like with your phone and
through like pictures and stuff it's
pretty much created this like new
language
I don't think emojis should be words I
think that's a dangerous road to go down
because soon we'll just be not
communicating we'll just be staring at
each other is that the only emoji that
got in like that even top ten emoji poop
emoji should go in we'll check in with
you about the coast I think that people
who are using the crying laughing emoji
are using it in lieu of actual humor and
they are we people okay I have something
to say that crying laughing emoji number
one top emoji everyone I suppose yes
please my point cruise my phone you're
wrong I'm right
it's here here what get it there I got
it yeah it's here